hello everyone and this is chess in the
Romantic era with Grandmaster Denis
boorish and today I'm going to give you
a special treat as this is the duel
between the two grandfathers can anybody
tell me who Qi Graham was grandfather -
well obviously the Russian chess and
Marazzi
is the Hungarian the grandfather of
Hungarian chess so it's kind of very
exciting to see how they fought against
each other and you'll see how originally
how original they're played play are
alright c49 up 6 v 4 and 6 at c3 d5
Knight f3 this is kind of like a weird
transposition usually everybody takes on
d5 now Knight f3 c 6d 397 and guess what
a modern Slav defense and we're only in
the 1900s Bishop d3 Bishop d6 yes castle
before and obviously I wanted to start
with one of their few games where it's
kind of more solid so we can't pick up
the speed in the last two games D takes
e4 e5 now this is this classical
structure it's very very popular these
days
but obviously not many of the guys
played this in the 1900s this is kind of
original it still is a little bit
original usually they play Queen c2
first let's say age 6 and then they
transpose into this line
so Marat cplay d-4d takes e5 Bishop g5
he's trying to destabilize black also
pinning the Queen really seven King
gauge one group the eight in situ eight
six Bishop takes f6 I'm not a big fan of
that move Bishop age for stills feels
better than this one taking you give
away a bishop for not much and that's
not great takes D takes e5 and now
you'll see
chigorin shine his next move is very
beautiful
strategically beautiful what did she go
and play here the grandfather of Russian
chess
Hindes he captured back
yes and if I take you
what's she Goren's plan and if the
bishop moves
you play Queen f4 I'll chase you with g3
so I'm quite sure she Goran would have
anticipated this and it has a beautiful
strategic concept in mind what could
that be
I think you're going the right direction
with Queen f4 you kind of tried to stop
bite from rolling you overwrite with f45
I think she Gordon had the same thing in
mind but had a different move plant yeah
Knight G six no yes no not Queen age
form
in Jesus
it's g5
which is a beautiful idea and it's now
very typical and many names of Indians
and Slav structures the concept is based
on this if you get f4 I'll take you and
this night will be eternal
you can never remove it from there and
that will compensate me for this
pawns being isolated and if g3 then we
have the strategic idea of g4 obviously
now Bishop h3 comes into consideration
but if it wouldn't work
g4 would strategically destroy by its
concept because as long as this Knight
is ruling the kingside black is better
also this Bishop is kind of passive now
so it's kind of remarkable that she
göran in the 1900s came up with this
concept of giving away the bishop there
just to get a stable central night
tomorrow what's he said no no thank you
I'm not going to take on e5 rook e8
insisting because he would do the same
thing if he would take he says okay no
Bishop e2 Bishop c7 so as the Bishop
moved what changed what changed in the
position
yes
yeah so if plaque would be unsuspecting
and play Asics for some mysterious
reason you could take take a four and
the night no longer attacks that bishop
on c4 and what would just start pushing
the pawns and why there's just much much
better so chigorin aware of that plays
Bishop c7 saying I have the bishop pair
I have no problems moving my bishop 9191
is kind of mysterious move but it does
plan to do 93 f4 and do some damage in
the center but as we will see it will
not work 95 °f for not g4 now even
though white managed to play f4 ideas of
Queen h4 and Knight takes h2 tricks
might become real let's say if I would
play the unsuspecting Queen b3 how can
black punish this immediately a very
very nice idea for black yes
9h to King takes h4 King g1 and Bishop
d6 check and sadly you can't really stop
me from taking all your stuff and rook
f2 obviously fails to Queen to accept -
so we're like on move 18 and chigorin is
already much much better
Bishop digs g4 but Maruti is a very
strong player he's a top he was in the
top 10 around this time so he senses the
danger takes rook d3 defending the rook
rook b8 just bringing all of his guys
into the play was just very good
me enough to again a very sly idea he's
waiting for black to take and hoping
that you know things will turn out well
takes takes rook da and again we can
clearly state that black is much better
because the rook is entering the whites
position these bishops are just
paralyzing light so this is already very
nice for black in g3 Bishop e6 b5 Queen
f5 95 you can see that white already
found a little bit of play he was
waiting to get a little bit of counter
chances which will not prove enough but
at least he tried Bishop takes e5 nice
little tactical trick by chigorin
obviously morose he cannot take because
the rook is hanging so he takes on e6 F
takes in six we need three Bishop takes
why didn't he take on c3 why did he take
on c3 here the powerful Bishop and yet
he took on c3 what is the idea behind
this yes
can you speak up I don't hear you
yeah he wants to create weaknesses for a
white also like is upon up there's no
reason not to exchange pieces BTech c3b
six
it's just defending this a7 pawn h3
looked III and again the difference
between the activity of the pieces
decide the game this rook is way more
passive this than this rook on d3 and
that's the decider Queen e2 just takes
the pawn in a six in d5 kim ji-won
rook C to look at three it's basically
agony already and after a queen d1 he
resigned as rook f1 wouldn't help like
can go just Queen d2 and it's just
threatening terrible checkmates and if
you go H to Queen takes after he wins
the game so this was a very nice and
quick game by chigorin showing really
high-class all right so let's take a
look at this revenge game so in 1905
Marazzi gets another chance of playing G
Goren but this time he's going to try
harder
d4 d5 now chigorin mixes it up who
doesn't play Knight f6 which would
transpose to our previous game he plays
Bishop b4 d39 f6 Bishop d3 now does
anybody know who is this line named
after this variation
yeah Rubinstein yes of course it's
Rubinstein it's Akiba Rubinstein very
famous for playing this III systems if
you want to find some really cool games
with this variation you might want to
look up some of the games of Boris
Gelfand who's a renowned fan of
Rubinstein castles Knight f3 and
actually be directly transposed to this
main line 97 but 97 is a little bit too
artificial how do they usually play here
the black or what would you play look
black in this position yes take on c4
and how it usually continues this c5
castle takes and this is we know it as a
carpel variation that he played it a lot
of times did very good results so Knight
d7 which is a little bit off it's not a
good move castle rook e8 Queen b3 double
attacking and as you can see if you get
the chance double attack
cuz now chigorin will be forced to part
with his bishops maybe he's not too sad
about that because he loves his knights
but in this special case is going to be
an advantage for murat c b6 and this is
a classical position where bishops fight
nights and if we have the bishops what
should be aiming for is white
yes
opening the position so Marazzi takes on
d5 hoping to get a bigger scope for this
guy on c1e takes d5 the reason black
doesn't take with the night is that
would make it way more easier for white
to open up the position and could even
go if or if wood really wants to the
idea of expanding or just even pushing
black off the board
therefore chigorin takes of the pawn or
should we continue with white marathi
style
well we should keep opening the position
up it should be to see for our bishops
one freedom and those Knights can't
really do much against them maybe block
their way but that's all they can do not
afraid now obviously we will consider it
d takes i like that if taking with the
bishop because we would have heavy heavy
pressure on the f7 pawn but even if you
would take this way I would never be
scared of Bishop takes f3 because G
takes f 3 and you need bishops to
actually exploit these weaknesses the
knight would take like 1 2 3 moves to
attack it but I can just stop you from
doing that but playing one pawn move so
it takes you forever to attack me and
mine is just clearly better and just
notice that my bishops are just staring
at your king it's obvious the QI going
one none of that and plays Knight f 895
why does she
why does morote supposed the knight on
e5 well because it's a well covered
outposts and knights love those places
obviously chigorin goes and challenges
it but rook d1 what we want is a nice
little move kind of anticipating some
exchanges but if we start exchanging
this Queen we'll be in trouble
this is what we call being in the x-ray
not h4 which is not a great move I don't
like night h4 it's kind of being tricky
when tricks don't really help you what
should black do instead
you can find your way out of some
trouble that'd be grateful the black
pieces Queen to c8 it's a reasonable
idea but Queen see it is a bit passive
can we make a little bit more active
move but pawn takes c4 just helps me I'm
looking for a queen move that is not as
passive as Queen c8 I don't like this
move because it's just too passive there
but it yeah Queen e7 that's the good
move just getting out of this x-ray and
I'm still firmly believing that might is
better here because this bishops are
just tremendous but black is still
fighting especially if white takes then
at least we will get a really nice
Bishop on d5 so Knight h4 is tricky but
it's not good and white please f3
usually this is not a great move but
this time this kind of blocks the way of
this Bishop and if you can minimize the
efforts of your opponent's pieces you're
getting closer to victory especially in
this close type of position where they
can't really use the fact that you play
that three like in an open position this
move of f3 would be a little bit more
sketchy not in this position in c8 again
a move I don't really approve of in situ
not rushing he knows he can take on d5
anytime he wants and he wants to take
when this knight on f6 is already kind
of having a hard time moving between c2
d takes bishop takes c4 and you can see
that she gore and loses patience here
blacks best that would be just to sit
and wait for something to happen
D takes c4 Bishop takes c4 bishop d5 but
this is already the beginning of the end
Queeny for just activating the Queen and
look at all those miserable pieces by
black all scattered and also it's a
double attack between the eight just
just defending everything in due time
f4 it's getting ready to attack and just
March up the board g6 and III have six
and here Marwood C plays a very very
nice move and plays like a boss how did
my Road C play like a boss here
would we want to move that night from e5
not really we don't want to move that
night that's a happy night there but can
we do something else yeah efore and he
says I'm gonna challenge you if your
knight moves you'll be in big trouble
let's say the knight moves I already
have this deadly check on b3 if you move
here I'll call check then you're done if
you go to g7 and check you an f7 check
you here and this will and sad so you
must take on e5
and now Murat C plays the best move
possible in this position
muroids he realizes that there are some
hidden hidden technical hidden tactical
motives in this position Queen C 4 well
I can still take on that force so that
would be a little bit too much but
indeed Maruti will try to use the fact
that the black king is super exposed yes
F takes me five yeah D takes d5 now that
takes e5 is probably also really good
but D takes e5 opens up the bishop a
little bit more and also it has a trick
up his sleeve because if he plays c6 but
if he will play like night before I have
this check that you've been mentioning
and then I just kept you a queen if you
take with the F pawn you can't do that
you'll be able to give a check but the
rook wouldn't be able to capture the
Queen
therefore Marazzi takes with the deep on
c6 between b3 and this is again a super
rare necessarily move he wants to keep
the Queen's on the board if he would
take on d5 I would take with the Queen
forcing you to exchange the Queen's I'm
not saying that white is not much much
better but black can fight because the
Queen's are off the board so Gizem rotc
goes Queen b3 I'm not interested in
extending this game longer I'm just
going to take on d5 with full effect
mean c8 he takes the 5c takes d5 we
sixty-five meaning six Brooksie one
he's just getting ready to prepare the
invasion King h8 Luke c7 not a five rook
d7 h 5 h 3 look this h 3 move is
actually very cool it's not only
preparing this idea of G for getting rid
of this super not at 5
it also creates a little bit of a hiding
place for the White King to hide and
this is what many unexperienced players
forget about that even if you're winning
you still should be a little cautious
and create a little bit of lift for your
king to hide Age 3 and after H 3
chigorin respectfully resigned seeing no
way to really go against this G 4 idea
and seeing no other ways to challenge
Maruti's king to show you all of these
typical classical games by chigorin and
Murat C now let's get down to business
and do a little bit sharper games will
start with chigorin's game from 1903
against my road scene when he was black
before he v in near riding 1903 so guess
what chigorin played here obviously
the king's gambit he takes a floor and
obviously chigorin as talented as he was
he knew what the best move is in this
position you see in my previous lecture
you'd already know the answer by now the
move is Bishop c4 one of Fischer's
favorite move and I think he also
considers this one of the best moves
obviously Knight f3 is an idea Knight c3
was played by reports so it deserves a
mention but Bishop c4 is clearly the
best one now Murat C knows this plays d5
which is one of the best moves Bishop
takes me five but then he makes a
mistake what move could be potential
mistake here
yes matter of six actually is one of the
best moves
surprisingly the very normal looking
check is inaccurate because seemingly it
helps black to get closer to the white
king but this Queen will be changed away
soon enough
Genie f1 and the problem is that in the
near future white will play Knight f3
and change the screen away c6 Knight f3
Bishop c4 this was the game we saw
between kuru SEC and lost cur in which
car was a quant later on here Marazzi
played g5 and she go in place one of
those moves that makes this whole gambit
so exciting it's white to move and just
start immense complications
any ideas back there how could white
create chaos and just get closer to that
f7 pawn at all costs
yes well if you take on f7 your bid
still underdeveloped to do that it's a
cool move but what she Gore in place
ones the same thing what does she go I
want to do
g3 she's a pretty cool move F takes and
the best badass move is Queen f3 I don't
care about those bones I'll just check
nature and he's right
even the computers agree that g3 is a
super strong move and Morosi realizes
that this is very dangerous and gives
the pawn back well if you would take on
h2 I would just decimate you on the
kingside and you're just gonna lose so
you can't do that
and if Bishop e6 I'll take you first and
then I'll take you and this will hurt
quite a bit you're losing that rook so
shockingly here I'll move seven and
Black has this only move g2 just quite
remarkable King pigs g29 h6
being g3 Bishop d6 and suddenly you
reach this really weird M game if you
think about it who could be potentially
better here
yes
well the saying black is better I would
disagree because I have the better
center and you have awkward pieces I'd
rather be white here with GA taking f1
and funnily enough this Bishop age to
the idea doesn't work because I would
just take you these Kings gambit
positions are just hilarious
Brooke g6 d5 and the more passive black
gets the more clear against that white
is just better there should be seven we
should be for just chasing that rook
away not a five-night c3 developing some
pieces
Brooke g4 not GE two he goes to e 2
instead of Knight f3 to give space for
this Bishop on that three and Kings
gambits are very complicated if you
would put the knight on f3 you might get
into big trouble just because you didn't
provide one square for the bishop also
white is playing with fire this King is
still in the middle even though there's
lots of pieces around it
one slip the position opens up and why
get gets brutally made it died c6 and
that's what black is aiming for 96
Bishop f3 from g8 back Knight b5 so he's
also trying to dis coordinate my roses
pieces before they would get too active
Bishop d8 and this is already a sign
that she Goran has a splendid position
c3a 693 now I you might say that this
knight on a 3 looks funny but because of
this close nature of the position Mike
will have time to reroute the Knight to
c4 c2
and if he'll be able to reorganize
everything and all of his pieces this
will be a great game for him have six as
I told you my roots is trying to open up
the position Bishop h5 check again
trying to play the spoiler and discord
innate all the black pieces
he takes King takes not f4 and
surprisingly is the black King that it's
in trouble with my knight and Bishop
getting closer to the king
97 Bishop d2 bring in another fellow
into the game
we should have five lucky 196 King f2
and suddenly who's King is in danger
well that's blacks and black is in big
trouble right now h3 very nice little
idea trying to prepare this bishop h4
trick rope g1 king f7 rook F 1 and these
are kind of shadow moves obviously
chigorin sees Bishop h4 and he says okay
Brooke f1 if you want to chase me I get
ready for it and you'll be the one
pinned so King g7 Bishop g4 finds Bishop
g4 such a great move in this position
well the reason is simple white actually
wants to get rid of the only active
piece of black therefore the exchanges
at the Bishop g4 Bishop doesn't take
place real cat fate King d2 and the
problem is if black would exchange in g4
yes he does these ideas of 96 will be
super super strong and it's not easy to
deal with these so Murat see facing all
these tough tasks please look at five
but this is losing its why to move and
web
yes
Knight takes g6 yes and if I take you
Knight f4 check and probably this is
what Murat seemed is that this new
sudden return of the night just wins Dan
piece and the game I assume he expected
night II 6 check where he would have
this King f6 move saving the game and
prolonging it also double attacking so
that's a kind of a nice trick that he
set up there but obviously chigorin is
not falling for that one in I just win
it and after Knight takes g6 Marvelettes
he resigned and that leads us to gain of
the day 1903 in this game Margaret C
plays a 4 B 5 and guess what he plays
here
guess what he plays here the King's
gambit of course takes Knight f3
so Morrow it C goes and plays the
traditional line the Knight f3 line
which I'm not saying is worse than
Bishop c4 but probably I would prefer
Bishop Seaforth given the champs g5
Bishop c4 g4 and now Marazzi shows how
to play in the romantic era he plays a
very very nice move here yes
castles away to sack the Knights but he
doesn't play that 195 displayable he
doesn't play that probably not h6 are
still good against that
no he doesn't take on f7 you usually
keep your whites squared Bishop for a
later attack you don't want to part with
that unless it's winning so he plays
Knight c3 bringing the knight in
planning to go to d5 G takes f 3 green
takes F 3 so if you've been keeping
score chigorin is a point up in their
personal duel so Maruti is trying his
best to equalize d6 d4 not afraid of
anything
and even though white is down the piece
for a pawn he is going to capture at the
f4 pond very soon and look at that mess
for black
there's nothing develop there so clearly
white has played there should be six a
very normal move but Murat see finds a
great solution against this one as well
what would you play here with white
would you exchange on e6 would that be
advised the piece down definitely not
if you wouldn't want to move our bishop
but then what can we do
yes
d 5 on d5 if you play pawn to e5 you
close up your Bishop and in the Kings
gambit the heart and soul of this game
for white is the c4 Bishop if it doesn't
work anymore you're lost if it functions
you're still in the game
so d5 wouldn't be a great idea so how
can we keep attacking and not losing the
c-4 bishop yes
95 exactly you play like Maruti 95 c6
and now the classy castles he's going
all-in he's taking no prisoners C takes
d5
he takes d5 you should at 5 Bishop takes
f4 and morothy has the romantic so he's
down to pieces
and he says not a problem I'm gonna
check me at you now computers find
defenses in these positions but it's not
that easy to defend when you're just
sitting there contemplating which be
smooth the computers suggest like ideas
of Queen h4 check and the King d8 but
it's kind of its kind of tough to find
this and even if white goes Bishop b5 k
d8 rook e1 there are some real threats
and trust me it's not that easy to move
around with the black pieces especially
like 97 you can go c4 in the near future
White Knight tried to open up its e5 and
e6 so the computer might hate this
but in reality this is quite a promising
attack for Marazzi now we should have 5s
plate and she go and played Bishop g6
which is not as good Bishop b5 check 97
it's not always a bad thing to pin your
opponent's king especially if you want
to conserve an attack so white plays a
bouquet one we should be seven ship
takes c6 look look how thin chigorin's
king is it's not the pleasant thing
experienced King f8 and now Murat C
comes up with the hammer blow
yes rook takes e7 yes rook e1 and it's
getting tough
it's getting really tough Samar wussies
sacrificing everything whatever he finds
in a storage he throws to the flame and
now it's trouble because even though
you're up look and a piece it will not
save you because they're just in the
storage room doing nothing
rook e1 King g7 Bishop takes e7 in a 5
you need to probably hoping that he
could double attack and this would be of
benefit to him but we need to defend
everything and with these two bishops
paralyzing black even though white is a
rook down he's clearly winning
especially that he is planning to push
the pawn to d6 and there will be no
movements for black black play Knight f8
trying to consolidate but Maruti is in
fire this game and plays the winner move
here it's a white to move and Webb
yes Bishop f6 if I take you Keeney five
mate which is quite a pretty sight with
all of the black pieces scattered the
lone white queen mates on e5
now chigorin obviously don't want any of
that to play King g8 but then Queenie
five and you can't really stop me from
taking that rook h6 is again if you take
on b5 Bishop takes h8 and in the old
times actually you would say that in one
move I will checkmate you sometimes you
will tell your opponent that checkmate
is incoming and you could do so
pointing out that Queen g7 will be my
next move
okay unless you play Knight II 6 but
then that would be just a nasty thing to
do just resign so h6 was played Bishop
takes h8 f6 fini 7 just making sure she
Gordon doesn't have any funny business
meaning if takes he'd still be breathing
after Queen c7 he says no no thank you
no such fun as needed King takes h8 mean
f6 and black resigned because he saw
after King g8 rookie 7 and again will
say I'm going to checkmate you in two
moves Bishop f7 takes takes
and checkmate this is how you checkmate
in the Kings gambit if your Marazzi
and this meant that the final score
personal score between Morrow D and
chigorin is to two which is quite
fitting for the two grandfather's the
grandfather's of Russian chess and the
grandfather of Hungarian chess playing
each other and I hope you like this game
played by Marazzi
against chigorin in this games gambit
game
thank you
[Music]
you
[Music]